I want to remind you that as Donald Trump
has been imploding and humiliating himself,
as more and more states flip to Joe Biden,
Donald Trump has also continued to fail, fail,
fail on coronavirus, and the pandemic has
gotten completely out of control.
Donald Trump promised 100 million vaccine
doses by the end of October.
That's a week ago.
Didn't happen.
And unfortunately, it pains me to say it.
Dr. Forces' estimate of 100000 cases a day
is going to end up being way too conservative.
Yesterday, we had another new record one hundred
and 18000 cases in a single day with more
than 1100 deaths.
As we look at the chart of new cases, you
see a horrifying trajectory of cases going
higher and higher and higher, the worst we've
seen in the United States.
And when you look at deaths, although there
is a delay there, the average death numbers
have been increasing for the last three weeks.
We are regularly seeing 11 hundred and twelve
hundred deaths a day again, and they are expected
to go much higher soon.
We are now approaching in total in the United
States, 10 million cases of coronavirus.
We have passed two hundred and forty one thousand
official deaths.
And remember, the estimated numbers under-represent
the real coronavirus death toll by as much
as 60, 70 or even eighty thousand additional
deaths.
And Donald Trump has failed and leaving is
an emergency.
His we need.
I was going to say we need new leadership
on the virus.
We need leadership on the virus.
Not a guy threatening to fire Fauci, but a
guy who says, Dr. Fauci, we need you to address
the nation.
Dr. Fauci, join me in a White House Oval Office
address.
Let's start to get this under control.
Donald Trump could have coasted to reelection
had he taken this seriously.
He didn't.
And he still almost won, which we will be
discussing more next week.
But contrary to what Donald Trump is has been
saying, coronavirus doesn't disappear.
On November 4th, Donald Trump really seemed
to believe it was a political ploy just to
hurt him.
And that November 4th, you would never again
hear about the virus.
We've not been hearing about it as much because
we're still trying to count all the ballots.
There is a pandemic raging.
We need adult leadership immediately.
Let's hope let's hope that we get that soon
because the next two months are going to be
brutal.
And hopefully if we have a lame duck trump,
we will start to get leadership elsewhere.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Remember the coupon code, brand new coupon
code, fresh start, fresh start, all one word.
Use it to save 70 percent at join Pakman dot
com.
We will see you today on the bon